omar so confession i'm not a big bird
person but i needed to wear birds today
in solidarity in solidarity with my
favorite it's not my favorite my fellow
canadian player don't tell marianne or
dre that i
good to see you today good to see you
and you're a monster for hating birds
but i love their funeral representation
you have right now for the national bird
of india as well
there you go i really invitation
i really thought this one out didn't i
well
it's been a while since that what that
blind side it looked like a blind side
for everybody watching so how are you
feeling right now after you've processed
it i feel great you know
going on the show you know most people
are going to lose and i was one of the
losers and that's fine like i still got
to play my favorite game my favorite tv
show and i had a great time out there
and i've had a great time watching it
back and sharing it with everybody so
there's no hard feelings like it was a
game and i i loved every second of it
well it sounds like you've added some
new vocabulary to the survivor
dictionary and you coined the term
survivor confident so how survivor
confident were you feeling
as you saw jeff reading the votes um i
was survivor confident until i saw
romeo
that's not part of the plan so i knew
something was wrong when i saw the first
one and when i saw the second i was like
uh oh
i feel like there's about to be a train
of me coming and lo and behold it was me
were there any signs before you went to
tribal council that it could have been
you yes i'm so stupid i'm such an idiot
because there were so many signs in
hindsight and you know i had not been
left out of a boat um everybody had been
telling me the truth up until that point
in the game so i didn't really have a
lot of experience
with um the other side
the other side the dark side and so it
was like when mike would pull me aside
four or five times before tribal council
being like there's a plan to the same am
i being played
and he wasn't doing that with me i
should have clued in when jonathan would
look at me and just whisper are we good
like
eight to ten times every night and he
wasn't doing that
i should have been a clue when marianne
came to me out of nowhere as i'm just
laying there and was like
what are we gonna eat together on the
final night at ponderosa on day 26 like
you're not getting your own food we're
gonna order together i was like that's a
bit that's a bit odd it's a bit weird to
say
and um you know
i just talked myself into not being
paranoid but i should have been
oh it's these little things the little
things get you in the end but something
that we saw some chatter about on the
episode and people were surprised about
it looked like lindsay had considered
using her idol to save you so can you
tell us what actually happened there and
why she didn't end up doing that yeah so
we had a conversation on the beach and
it was a little bit longer than the one
they showed but basically i had asked
her to use it on me because um that i
felt like you know it's the last time
you use it we're probably fine but what
if we're not you know and it's you don't
want to get survivor confidence so you
should use everything that you have at
your disposal but with the stipulation
of the um rules as far as i'm aware it
said it was non-transferable so she
would have had to play it on me in front
of everybody as opposed to giving it to
me to play was our understanding and so
i think she was very hesitant to make a
big
public display
of loyalty to me because then going into
the final five would be a duo against
three people and for me my game was not
about being pushy so i didn't want to
like force her to do something she was
uncomfortable with because i thought i
might lose her trust and her trust was
very important in that moment and i
wasn't i didn't feel i was in enough
danger to really push it but obviously
hindsight being 2020 it was a
mistake well i hear you 100 because it's
not as simple as just playing an idol it
also matters what statement is made at
tribal council and i do want to rewind a
little bit because when drea was voted
out she made quite the statement about
you she kind of threw you under the bus
so do you think that drea's parting
words affected your game yeah it's
really hard to know um
how a subjective thing like that
translates to
you know
objective effect i suppose i would say i
think that for mike and jonathan it
really had nothing to do with it because
the reason jonathan turned on me was
that i shared information about an
advantage to the idol nullifier with
lindsay
and that's something that he and i had
shared together so by breaking his trust
by telling her
he realized lindsay and i were closer
and he decided to go separate ways from
me and he told mike about the nullifier
and mike turned on me and then with
marianne the words treya had and as well
as seeing me hand the idol back to mike
because mike insisted it happened right
away after we got back and i was like we
should be more discreet but he's like
not right now and so i handed it back to
him and she saw that and i think that
was really jarring for her because she
realized i was playing a bigger game
than i um
had led on up until that point so i
think you know it probably played a
partial role with marianne maybe
solidified a role with the other two i
think it's very probable that it would
have been me regardless um and i don't
have any hard feelings for her saying
that because when i made the move
against her i knew that that's something
that could happen because it's not
against the rules
well i i do want to ask about your
relationship with marianne because on
twitter we've asked fans if they have
any questions for you and um
so frank frankenwenz asked did you ever
consider that marianne might use her
extra vote against you
it's so um i guess it's such such poetic
justice i would say like very like
shakespearean because you know going
into that merge all eyes were on
marianne like she as soon as tori won
immunity all the guns were pointed at
her from the majority alliance and um
i
was like i want to eat my chocolate cake
and i want to eat it too or i want it i
want to have it and i want to eat it too
so i literally was like
marianne you're not going home i'm going
to save you your extra vote and your
advantage
your idol and i'll keep them all in the
game and i'm thinking like oh like i'll
reap the benefits of that and then look
what gets used to cut me loose it's kind
of funny in hindsight but i didn't think
that she would use it on me
but i also kind of thought that we would
have to use that earlier in the game to
keep taku in the lead and i was
surprised that you know as we were going
along the target was always shifting to
somebody not on taku so we didn't have
to use it but i anticipated using it a
bit earlier but we didn't need to
and then it ended up on me
omar maybe you got survivor greedy too
yeah
well on that note there was another
question from a fan on twitter so john m
gallagher wanted to know
was the taku4 a real thing yes it was
very much a real thing and um you know
they were my primary loyalty throughout
the game i think there were points
especially with high where i really
felt very bonded to him and was like
maybe i should go a different direction
but ultimately i was like i'm going to
try to keep my high drea alliance and my
taku alliance in as long as possible
before having to make a decision
and with taku we were very intentional
going like we bonded so early because
jackson leaving really was tough on us
and mariah leaving so soon after that
we felt like we only had each other and
we had to work together and so going
into the merge our plan was to spread
our tentacles out spread our wings if
you will fly in different flocks so
nobody would know that we were all
working together and we would have
check-ins like five or ten minutes or
two or three minutes here there
i didn't talk to lindsay for the first
two days after the merge marianne i had
a 30-second conversation with jonathan
and i would talk in groups but not
really with each other
and it was really intentional for us to
kind of spread our tentacles out and um
get a hold on the game and it just ended
up working out and people be like oh
it's weird that you're all still here
and i'd be like yeah what a coincidence
like that's okay
but it was intentional i would say but
then
all my baby chicks that i was trying to
keep together ended up murdering their
mother so what can you say
the bird
metaphors don't stop and they just get
more graphic as you go
well you did have some touching moments
when you were out there and i want to
ask about some of them in last night's
episode there was that really sweet
moment when jeff had a shout out for
your niece hannah so what was that like
did she watch it and what was she
thinking yeah i watched that with her
and she was like so
thankful for that moment i think she was
a little bit like oh i'm not afraid of
stuff but i'm like yes you are
and uh but she i think she was really
thought it was a very special moment and
even little zara my other niece was like
a little bit jealous that she wasn't
mentioned but then i was like zara
you're fearless like you're not like
hunna and me you'll do whatever it and
you don't care so you don't need jeff's
life lesson but
shout out to her too
okay we don't want her getting survivor
greedy i'm glad that you were able to
shout her out too um
there were also so many moments where
you were so open about being authentic
to yourself and really practicing your
faith on tv i think we had never seen
anything like that on survivor before so
what was the response like from the
muslim community
you know it was very warm and it was
very i was very very thankful to have so
many people reach out and be like oh
it's so great to see somebody like you
on tv representing our community
especially when it really hasn't been
represented in any real way and my goal
out there like i knew i could go in with
the burden of having to represent a
community but i purposely
intentionally put that aside to some
extent because i was like i think that
will only hurt my game so i wanted to be
authentic to myself
and play the game kind of separate from
that but it was very special for
survivor to still share that part of me
because i did i do think it meant a lot
to a lot of people and growing up it
would have meant a lot to me to see as
well um so i'm hoping that feeling that
i had where you know our people didn't
really belong on a platform like this or
we were lucky
you know to be around other people who
were more important than us
i hope that little kids now don't feel
that way because they have someone to
represent them
and i think that that's why you were so
popular with the viewers because we got
to see this human side of you and we
also got to see you play the game and i
think that yes you were a popular player
i know you were popular here at et
canada too i know people speak highly of
you so i've got to ask what was it like
representing canada on 42
i am so proud to be canadian honestly
like i think it's the best country in
the world i think that we're so
fortunate enough in canada to have so
many opportunities that we wouldn't
otherwise have and my parents came here
for a better life um for their family so
um i've been so blessed by this nation
and i i love how patriotic canada is and
how they get behind their people and
it's just been so
amazing to represent the country that i
love so much and i hope that i did them
proud
you definitely made canada proud with
your performance out there and now so
there's one episode left you're going to
be on the jury so now that you're going
to be a juror what are you looking for
in the winner for survivor 42
i think for me i'm very open to voting
honestly for any of them in the final
three as long as they can demonstrate
what their game was and for me it's very
important to have intentionality behind
that game so you can play any strategy
you want
whether it's a popular strategy or not
based on like very arbitrary guidelines
set by fans but it's like if you play
the best game that you set out to play
no matter what that strategy was and you
were intentional about it i respect that
so for me i'm gonna vote for whoever
played the game that has the most
self-awareness and intention behind it
and that's important for me
amazing well omar it was so fun to watch
you it was so fun to have you represent
canada i wish you all the best as you
spread your wings and you head off to
whatever the next adventure is and
thanks so much for chatting today thank
you so much and bring more birds into
your life you'll be happy
[Laughter]
you